we've lost count of the times that
bizarre story lines from Springfield
actually came true but here are just a
few occasions when The Simpsons
freakishly predicted the future one of
many episodes that showed an alternate
reality future for Springfield's first
family BS to the Future aired in the
year 2000 and we learn Lisa has just
been elected president of the United
States during her first cabinet meeting
President Simpson mentions a familiar
name as you know we've inherited quite a
budget crunch from president Trump we
all know how the future turned out it's
worth mentioning that this particular
episode was written during Donald
Trump's failed presidential run in the
year 200000 and the writers themselves
saw the possibility of a trump
presidency as the most ridiculous thing
they could imagine for the future which
can only mean that Lisa Simpson is up
next and then president Kang all hail
president Kang could be worse we could
be eating soilent which is literally
named after ground up people from a
sci-fi movie starring chter hon wait
soent is food while not intended to
replace every meal soent can replace any
meal oh what a bleak horrible future we
live in in 1992's new kid on the Block
Homer sees a TV commercial for an all
you can eat seafood restaurant called
The Frying Dutchman Homer proceeds to
eat until closing time and gets kicked
out while still hungry he sues the
restaurant for false advertising but
Homer and the sea captain come to an
agreement come see bottomless Pete
Nature's Crest mistake come for the
freak stay for the fool in 2012 Bill wi
went to a Wisconsin restaurant called
Chuck's place for its weekly Friday
night fish fry Buffet after a few trips
to the restaurant and racking up a
running tab he wanted more but the
restaurant claimed they'd run out that's
when whis refused to pay we asked for
more fish and they refused to give us
any more fish the owner of Chuck's Place
claimed CL whis had eaten more than 20
pieces of fish and was violating the
buffet's no sharing policy he came back
with a vengeance and he wasn't done he
came back 2 days later with a picket
sign Wiest planned on picketing every
day but by early 2013 he had already
moved on to other protests but really do
these sound like the actions of a man
who had all he could eat no all that
could have been me over the course of
the series The Secrets of spring field
Elementary's lunchroom cuss cutting have
been explored again and again but even
lunch lady Doris has her limits what do
you want these beef H hearts on the
floor in the 1995 episode the PTA
disbands even darus objects to using
shredded newspaper and old gym mats as
ingredients POS shredded newspapers had
much needed roughage and essential inks
besides you didn't notice the old gym
mats there's very little meat in these
gym Ms in 2014 a minor but disgusting
scandal developed when the environmental
working group released a report that
found a compound called aod darkar
bomide in around 500 processed food
products primarily breads including
Pillsbury dinner rolls your favorite $5
Foot Longs and Wonder Bread so if you've
ever wondered what put the Wonder in
Wonderbread it's yoga mats and yoga is
totally healthy by season 2 Homer had
met his long lost brother herb but he
leaves Herb in financial ruin after he
bets his whole car manufacturing
business on a ridiculous car Homer
designs which was called The Homer
obviously any questions left destitute
he moves in with the Simpsons where he
creates a baby translator that turns an
infant's noise into English Maggie
Maggie whatever where did you go
peekaboo oh there you are very amusing
the original episode aired in 1992 and
by the year 2004 Japanese Tech and toy
company takura developed a real life
prototype of something very similar
after previously selling a device that
analyzed the sounds of dogs barking the
Prototype analyzed the baby sounds
facial expressions and body temperature
to alert parents if the baby was hungry
tired or needed to be changed while the
final product never emerged other
companies took the Reign and produced
other devices to analyze the fleshy wet
loud riddles at our infants ensuring
that you'll always be able to completely
emotionally detach from your helpless
Offspring
yay at the end of the saved Lisa's brain
a 1999 episode in which Lisa and her
local Mena chapter attempt to rule
Springfield with their Superior
intellect the smartest guy in the world
makes a cameo physicist and cosmologist
Steven Hawking and he has some very
interesting ideas your theory of a donut
shaped universe is intriguing Homer I
may have to steal it wow technically the
shape of a donut is a Taurus and yes as
it turns out the universe may actually
be shaped like the delicious confection
4 years after Homer Simpson proposed the
theory cosmologists noticed radiation
patterns in space suggesting that the
Universe was round and Tube likee but
empty in the middle and that's not the
only time hom has being the smartest man
in Springfield I am smart I am to smart
I am to
smartrg I mean a rrg while first
proposed in 1964 it wasn't until 2013
that physicists discovered the higs
bosan the field that basically holds
atoms together in other words the
discovery helps to define the very
fabric of existence and helps to
maintain How the Universe and matter
work and once again Homer was on The
Cutting Edge of Science in the 1998
episode The Wizard of era green Terrace
Homer attempts to become a scientist and
inventor and is seen messing around with
some formulas on a chalkboard his
meaningless math actually gets pretty
close to the actual molecular weight of
the higs particle which out of an
infinite possible equations is pretty
impressive but more importantly when is
reality going to finally catch up with
the toilet chair believe me every man in
America will want to have
one G way got a poop the halim show of
the 2017 Super Bowl made headlines with
Lady Gaga delivering a performance that
was absolutely surreal featuring
Highwire stunts pyrot Technics and
Theatrical costumes having provided her
own voice for her 2012 appearance on The
Simpsons Gaga was definitely familiar
with her ear animated performance which
bore some striking similarities to her
Super Bowl show granted gargard
Springfield self was only a slight
exaggeration on her normally outlandish
persona it's me Gaga why is everyone
looking at my purple hair full of
bluebirds but this one is pretty spoton
the 2001 episode hungry hungry Homer is
all about Homer going on a hunger strike
to prevent the local minor league
baseball team the Springfield Isotopes
from secretly moving to Albuquerque
daning away my Hunger PS moving my feet
so my stomach won't hurt in 2002 the
minor league Calgary cannons announced
to move to Albuquerque and the local
paper published a poll asking readers to
come up with a new name for the team no
strangers to pop culture the name
Isotopes W with 67% of the votes while
the idea very clearly came from The
Simpsons Isotopes is appropriate for a
team moving so close to the LZ alamon
National Laboratory at least the power
plants in New Mexico can't possibly be
as bad as in Springfield right well in
Southern New Mexico Federal officials
have confirmed that a local nuclear
plant is leaking waste and releasing
radiation into the surrounding area nope
they suck to stay safe Isotopes The
Simpsons began life back in 1987 as a
segment on the Tracy Omen show one of
the Fox network First shows that means a
yellow hu family has been a staple of
the network since the beginning and a
search frequently pokes fun at its
corporate overlords and we can't watch
Fox cuz they own those chemical weapon
plants in Syria the 1998 episode when
you dish upon a star found Homer working
as a very annoying personal assistant to
the then married couple of Alec Baldwin
and Kim Basinger who voiced themselves
there are a number of jokes at the
expense of celebrities and Hollywood in
general thus allowing the show another
chance to slip in another joke about
Fox's business practices there's a brief
shot of the entrance to the 20th Century
Fox lot which a sign says is a division
of Walt Disney Company nearly two
decades later the actual Walt Disney
Company flushed with cash from numerous
successful blogbuster flicks acquired
21st Century Fox for a cool 71.3 billion
so now Disney actually does own Fox and
The Simpsons I kber curling is a unique
sport that involves a careful pushing
and sweeping of a large Stone on an ice
rink it's been a regular event of the
Winter Olympics since 1998 teams from
cold snowy countries like Canada Sweden
and Switzerland usually dominate the
medal count before 2018 Team USA had
reached the medal Podium only once when
the men's team won bronze in 2006 the
relative lack of American presence in
the sport added an extra air of
unlikelihood to the 2010 Olympic seam
Simpsons episode Boy Meets curl in which
Homer and Marge become a mixed doubles
curling Duo for Team USA they wind up
winning the gold medal an achievement
that was impr probably matched by the
real American men's curling team in 2018
even weirder about this Simpsons
prediction is that the show forsaw mixed
up doubles curling being an Olympic
event in the first place as it wasn't
part of the winter games lineup until
2018 USA
USA
oops the recurring character faton is a
big man in charge of Springfield's
legitimate businessman Social Club in
other words he's a local organized crime
bus he's been involved in a number of
shady and illegal activities and the
2002 episode Poppa's got a brand new
badge involved one of his weirdest
schemes ever Homer security company
spring Shield bust Fat Tony for gluing
cotton balls onto ferrets with plans to
sell them to a pet store by passing them
off as far more expensive toy poodles
despite the unusual nature of this plot
it was remarkably similar to one a real
life criminal actually attempted with
this latest arrest Springfield is now
free of crime although overrun with
ferrets in 2013 a retie visited the
massive lass Salada outdoor Bazar in bua
Aries Argentina and purchased two
poodles he took his new pet to a
veterinarian for a checkup only for the
doctor to discover that they weren't
poodles at all they were ferrets given
steroids to appear poodle size Bart and
Lisa love the Itchy and Scratchy Show
the cartoon segment on the Crusty the
clown show that features the unspeakably
Gory antics of aom and Jerry style cat
and mouse in the 1992 episode Itchy and
Scratchy the movie The promoters of the
Duos feature film have to pull out all
the stops so they install a billboard in
Springfield showing ity using a movie
camera to chop off scratchy's head blood
spews out of the billboard with every
chop to the Delight of drivers
[Music]
below then in 2008 when Quinton
Tarantino's Kill Bill volume 1 a work on
us as violent as Itchy and Scratchy made
its Australian TV debut the network TV2
contacted the advertising firm Sai and
Sai to inform the public it did so with
a billboard meets art installation in
which um Thurman's character the bride
held a katana that Unleashed so much
blood it exploded beyond the printed
panels and onto the side of a building
all over the street and onto white cars
parked below the 2010 episode Elementary
School Musical begins with Lisa and her
friends watching the announcement of
that Year's batch of Nobel Prize winners
they're more than a little bit nerdy so
they've all made predictions and printed
them out the Simpsons writers really do
their research for these scenes as they
aim to get the details just right for
even the briefest of sight gags the
friend group's little chart list 20
possible Nobel winners across five
categories and all of them are people
and outstanding members of their
respective Fields milhous has picked to
take home the big prize in economics is
bangar Holstrom a Finnish Economist and
MIT faculty member amazingly the usually
hapless mhouse got it right as Holstrom
really did win the Nobel Prize for
economics in
[Music]